ja ich habe unsere stattgefunden nach
sieben folgen bin ich endlich wieder zu
hause
oh mein gott und wir haben so eine fette
statue ist das geil ich mit salve
endlich seine statur und herzlich
willkommen zu einem teil des epischen
projekte und die haben diesmal einen
ganz besonderen gast und zwar den oft
meine lieben freunde und wir haben uns
gedacht indem einfach noch eine folge
auf gerade so gut gelaufen ist und ich
hier mit meinem chocobo wieder amrum
chillen bin in der homepage und da muss
ich noch mal fragen dürfen jetzt
bedenken macht ja was wurde zu diesen
stäben gesagt es wohl nicht gesagt man
darf sich die nicht kräften weil das ist
ein ganz normaler zauberstab mit dem ich
über die mauer springen kann
also ich weiß nicht genau ob ist der
zauberstab war bei mir haben die blöcke
in diesen komisches gitter irgendwie so
ein gelbes auf 9 gedreht 17 war das bei
mir kann ich das irgendwie umstände den
einstellungen erst mal ne frage gestellt
hat also ich habe nicht immer glatt
control zwischen schwimmt das mal ganz
kurz umzustellen und zwar wurde
bezüglich zauberstab gesagt ja das
irgend einen zauberstab oder im park
blöcke dürfen nicht gemacht werden weil
die irgendwie absturz des servers oder
irgendwas anderes damit herbeirufen aber
ich weiß jetzt seien nur vom server
fliegen das hat nicht nur im server zu
tun er flieg ich ja nur vom server
deswegen
wirklich meine ganzen scheiß auf warum
ich hab ja zum glück hatte ich finde ihr
gold und hab mir goldene feder gefunden
ich habe auch schon zwei hoch schoss das
heißt kennst du diese kredite aber hast
du noch mal ganz kannst du mal ganz kurz
pennen gehn oder ganz kurz vom server
gehen
fabian 8 ich liege im bett ich liege im
bett bin weg spiegelt also das ding ist
einfach nur ich bünder gratiskonten ich
flieg einfach auf dem turm drauf und so
ein mob ton und bin einfach die kiste um
hinweg das ja nicht verboten
das ist nicht vergrössern asozial aber
nicht verboten ist es auch nicht also
zusammen das glaub ich kommen und auch
alle gemacht ich denke das liegt daran
dass hatte ich schon manchmal bald als
ich angefangen aufzunehmen dass es sein
konnte dass das ein komisches geht aber
ich werde einfach gleich ganz so gleich
mal ganz kurz die aufnahme pausieren und
dann direkt weiter machen und dann von
einigen nicht weg soll ich bin jetzt das
ding sich im springer und versuche auch
mal gleich zum endboss zu springen in
diesem teil
lassen sie die ganzen kissen ich fühle
mich gerade mit einem schoko immer noch
weiter ich will eigentlich auch dieser
komischen das volant region langsam
schon wieder nein diese den schoko
mitnehme das wasser plätschert etwas
mulmig um ein schoko bist so süß ich so
auf einem chocobos gegen den kennst du
denn gerade das wissen hatte ich dachte
jetzt laufen heiß wenn er wieder sich
ein visiert der walking stand oben auf
dem turm
er kann sich eventuell ganz kurz die
kroaten sagen von unserem priceline also
wo ich mit oder was ich musste die
richtige laufen können
ja wo unsere stadtväter ist ich musste
als kind war das ding ist der macht so
ein zauber auf mich drauf dass er mich
irgendwie bewegt auch der krieg nur ein
schaden und der 250
ich bin echt zu weit gelaufen jetzt ist
es so krass so ich denke ich muss jetzt
nur noch 700 oder so laufen dann müsste
ich wieder bei uns in der stadt seien
eigentlich irgendwelche walker dann ach
du scheiße nach der damage wenn jetzt
sterben würden das war so traurig ohne
witz hier sind doch überall so komische
portale irgendwie gar das sind
dimensionen portal kennt sich damit aus
weil ich kann dir bis 14 erzähl mal ein
bisschen warte ich muss also ich würde
gerne jetzt die krones haben auf es gelb
drückt einzustellen
also das ding ist mit man hört mich
bestimmt so gar nicht so wendig
vorschlag machte sony fast fertig
gekauft papa muss abbauen
eventuell kann ich sogar ein grabstein
hole ich bin dann gleich wieder statt
ich baue hier schnell zu ich bau dir
schnell zu mit gold blöcken bodyguard
gebäude ist schon wieder so ganz viele
festungen
das besteht dass eine stadt ich habe mit
zeige und leiser zu stellen was zu essen
und jetzt kann ich erzählen die
dimension vorteile sind eigentlich ganz
gut wenn wir uns in komplett logisch
aufgebaut das heißt wenn du
beispielsweise wenn du zum beispiel in
einer dimension sterben sollte es kommt
so eine art unterwelt wird und so einen
roten see springen muss und dann bist du
jetzt wieder im normalen welt und es ist
so dass es so wie keine handtücher sowie
portals vorstellen also diese dimension
zum gipfel einer nachhaltig drei
möglichkeiten
irgendwo zwischen durch fenster als
super fallen die durch letzten gemacht
sind oder so oder paar kisten die auto
cool ist das zeugnis und ja sagt noch
gar nicht ganz nett gemacht ja ich habe
unsere stattgefunden
nach sieben folgen bin ich endlich
wieder zu hause wo mein gott und wir
haben so eine fette statue aus dass
kalla ich sah meine natur weil sie nicht
ihr sohn der stadt irgendwie so heftig
wie geil ich finde dich wieder zu hause
ja mein schoko wo kann ich denn
hinziehen
du kannst dir nicht vorstellen meine
hand grad weh tut weil der typ kriegt
pulsschlag bei mir nur 0 5 schaden wie
ich das sehe ist das geil klickst du
weißt gar nicht lieben ich glaube ich
bin so zu hause wie vor du bist die
ganze zeit einfach rumgelaufen im
niemandsland und konzert gar kein
irgendwie was machen jetzt bin ich
einfach wieder zu hause und in der nähe
und so ich freue mich so ohlmann alter
last ein verdammtes schilder und lucia
co2 und freunden chocobos jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen eingegraben also da sollte
jetzt eigentlich nichts passieren
ich mache ganz kurzen cut beende
kurztexte stadt wieder neu und dann
versuche ich dass die aufnahme wieder
leute ist das gemetzel weiter genau ich
habe noch ein weiter und bei mir.de
nicht so lange also tschüss und bis
gleich bei meiner liebe freunde ich
gerne wieder auf den server auf den bass
server ich glaube es müsste jetzt
klappen
ich denke ja ich würde gerne gerade noch
morgen in ja es klappt auf jeden fall
wieder alles bedankt euch mal bei mir
schreibt man alle applaus die kompakte
applaus applaus applaus applaus
wo kann ich mich dann jetzt hier anbauen
ich nehme es einfach mal ich glaube ich
hier wohnt niemand drin also jetzt aber
schon ein hausdach so richtig glücklich
aussieht wo ich gerade zwei kleine
village häuser verbindet das es war ein
baby und brocken
die haben uns aber das steht auch hier
residiert cap also verstehe ich möchte
eigentlich nicht neben region programms
woche platz ich komme einfach cool sie
nicht starten
wer jan ehrlich ich sehe schon was ca 1
ist das so ja das ist das war halb
abgebaut ist das haus hier steht evonik
plus vogel ja die beiden werden gerade
verbinden läuft also etwa ein polarbär
weg zu flexen und mit resistenzen sowas
hier haben auch schon schoko und ist ja
cool dann ziehe ich hier einfach einen
borders danach ein bisschen aus abu
dhabi katar als der endboss aber ich
freue mich so dass ich zu wieder bei
euch bin weißt du dass es irgendwie
richtig schön finde ich ja
doch aber erstmal wie durch ein paar
kisten das problem ist ich weiß gar
nicht was man so soll ich jetzt plündern
weil ich habe eigentlich alles meine
komplette richtung ist verzaubert
obwohl ich noch kein verzauberung tisch
gefallen aber das einzige was eigentlich
suche ist verzauberung zwischen
eigentlich will das ja auch leicht
überhaupt jemand ab ja schon wie viele
diamanten habe ich keine ahnung wie
schon 50 oder so 50 63 flächen snack für
unterwegs alter zoll ist eine dritte
route schon geplündert das also zu
sieben tischen so erläutert dann würde
ich sagen ab jetzt mein haus baut muss
natürlich auch mal sein ich werde mir
wahrscheinlich wollt ihr das nicht mehr
so ein paar gäste immer mal so in den
nächsten folgen einladen wenn ich so ein
hausbau dass ich mit den quatsch ich hab
das paddel gesehen hat mit floss ein
bisschen gequatscht da dachte ich mir
von euch nicht mehr aufmachen was haltet
ihr davon schreibt einmal die zuschauer
werden das sehr wohl wollen ich habe zu
wenig umfang auch schon gemacht und das
ist bisschen schöner denke ich manchmal
ein bisschen solar die frage macht hier
glaube ich auch aber ich möchte euch
trotzdem gefangen und der gast auch
immer ich kann meinen kommentar
schreiben was ist ein genie war blöd
oder das nächste piratenschiff warten
also ich kann mir das wort vom export
kann ich dir schenken ja du schenkst du
das und ich schenk dir eine schoko
federball dafür dann brauchst du keinen
schock opel hat schon eine goldene feder
dann mache ich den sattel jetzt ist das
schwert was ich habe ist besser als
wenig wert dass du
denn mutter sein agent diamonds wort
scheint deinen sport ja es ist
wahrscheinlich auch ein besser ist etwas
was macht man damit noch in burg warum
ich wieder ganz hoch zu ross um keine
ahnung hast ja das komische also damit
scheint ihr recht witzig zu sein
aber sobald du rechtsklick machst
kriegst du alt protection fünf trauben
drauf das heißt du dich immer nur ein
halbes jahr zu schaden
die sonne geht wieder unter aber das ist
egal weil ich jetzt in der stadt sind ja
und ich flieg grad auf irgendeinen turm
und hoffe und gratis tierpark rückgangs
nach wie vor dem turm herunter
das blöde ist jetzt allerdings auf dass
ich jetzt nicht so richtig weiß wie
lange ich schon auf nehme ich nehme
einfach mal so in fünf minuten länger
auf wie du das wissen über wir sind zu
viel
ok dann so drei minuten einfach familie
überall diese folgen sie uns über all
diese kisten mit irgendwelchen eisen
stiefeln die das ist einfach schon
kinder ja was schlecht sind jetzt gerade
ein pac man ja ja das klappt die damit
spricht abbauen
ja das wäre auch ganz cool der durch die
stadt kommt sondern dich in deinem bett
legt auf jeden fall erwarte ich so mein
haus ist jetzt mehr oder weniger
komplett aufgerissen ich weiß nicht wer
will nochmal so kunert hast du wenn man
sich dann weiter so was nicht bau das
dach glaube ich auch noch aus aber ich
habe immer mal so ein paar obsidian
teile gefunden überall ich suche
wirklich nur ein verzaubertes sich damit
in keinem bücherregal sein weil wir mit
dem gesten verzauberung swat drauf wo
man ein bisschen besser verzaubern kann
und das ding ist noch einfach nun
verzaubert uns zu stars wasser sonst
gehen die zauberstäbe so dermaßen
schnell kaputt und da sitzt du da so
haltbarkeit draus machen ja genau
haltbarkeit das kostet auch nur level
das ist einfach so das gehört sich aus
ist aber sofort hier gemacht also meine
haltbarkeit 3 drauf zaubern kann ohne
dass man level dafür braucht aber unter
direkt unter meinem haus ist eine höhle
als ich weiß nicht ob das eine gute idee
ist wenn ich mich direkt hier ein bauer
dort ist es dunkel und ich bin und ihre
bescheide sind jetzt wirklich direkt
eine höhle er hier ist ein portal
hallo aber ich seh grad strings dann
kann ich ja direkten sattel machen gegen
das portal oder nicht das ist eine
entscheidung dort versucht einfach für
den westen ein monolith fortmann das
genie angucken muss laut ok du musst
definitiv aus solchen höhen raus wenn es
gibt so monolith steimel kanal liegen so
kannst du dieses monster von pokémon
black ops braucht man grob dieses
econitor pokémon level wie teuer genau
so sehen die teile aus wenn du die
anguckt dann stürzt tut als ob sowie
diese dings wie er diese eine göttin da
wenn man die anguckt versteinert man ja
so manch stift aber nicht direkt oder
kommt für so eine art unterwelt wirklich
sterben lassen musste um wieder blicken
so irgendwie sowas ganz komisch ist ein
richtiger film da wieder rauszukommen
das ist crazy fast schon normal unnormal
ein du brudy ich mache jetzt ebenso
allerdings hatte ich weiß doch gar nicht
erst sich die angst ich kann nicht
einfach voll ausschütten wenn du nicht
bist ja bin ich noch nicht so richtig
ich habe auch mit spider hoch und eine
gremlin huck ich kenne mich damit noch
nicht so richtig aus wir schauen dass
ich meine dann auch zu mir cap was hast
du für ein glück dass beide hoch ist die
seltenste ob diese auf ihre hexe gibt ja
die habe ich aber irgendwie finde ich
nicht so duftet wie das ist das
überhaupt also die treppen hoch ist so
die kannst du kannst rechtsklick noch
einen haken raus dann kannst du dich
irgendwo hoch kino anziehen und die ist
bei hof ist glaube ich da kannst du das
gleiche machen und aber auch gegner ran
ziel unseres of cool ich weiß nicht mehr
genau das ist einzig die bringen soll
meisterlich
ja das wollte ich auch gott sagen oder
alter ach so ich dachte schon mal auf
pinguin der sich selber das wäre die
höchste schande alter einfahren pinguins
wir sind die erzeuger von allen einfach
dieser stadt auch sei ich laufe einfach
mal ganz fröhlich gelang gefallen so
dreckigen auch us eyes und here ist ein
lahmer sehen das heißt ich jetzt ganz
viel optimal versorgen bring mir bitte
auch was mit okay ich mache jetzt eben
sattel das wasser weiter leiten wird
irgendwann das gefühl hat das wird
nichts ich habe aber in meinem reisen
die beiden ja passt es nicht läuft bei
woche schaden krippenbau der crystal
ball schießt nur einbrecher bargeld zwei
teile schießt dort tätig ist jetzt mal
direkt von anfang an so ein bisschen so
nach wertvoll ich kite wertvolle
sportlichkeit und diese melo barry die
pflanze jetzt erst mal hier an weil das
wird jetzt erstmal so meine zu schreiben
gibt auch okay ich bin nur vier stück
metall so weil das dauert oder folgt das
dauert einfach zu lange sei wirklich
einfach zu lange die ab zu sammeln was
was denn jetzt immer noch kein effizienz
kein gar nichts laufen
das dauert so lange und ich wollte auch
in dieser folge zurück zur stadt ja klar
ich komme einfach zurück das ist jetzt
egal ob ich weiter dran was bringt diese
grünen teile was bringt emerald chart
das weiß ich auch nicht das ist einzige
was ich wirklich ist das zum traden oder
weil davon 36 irgendwie ich hab mal
geschaut ob man darauf vielleicht einen
großen start machen kann geht aber nicht
kann weil also du musst du musst quasi
ich habe gesagt für dich und ich habe
ein sattel für dich die muss quasi nun
schoko finden dann führt dass du ein
bisschen mühsam und dann weißt du dann
hast du dir denn einfach dann fahren
einfach fliegen
nein es gibt welche die fliegen können
fällig ja gibt ja bultaco special
features die ach so takko special
feature special features aluminium ob
erste eis festung und das geile immer
das erste mal hier rein
ich habe zum die hessen 2 es gelten
was kann ich damit machen was ich damit
machen kann mit den köpfen spukt der
boss macht alles kaputt die fotografie
kiste luton
aber ich bin ja kein inventar sortiert
jetzt ich brauche ohne witz ich brauche
cobblestone das ist traurig dass so was
hab ich brauche eine ikone wird was bin
ich für ein glücklicher gefunden
schockiert und hier kommt nichts
herunter ich habe das auch gehört wusste
und ich hab den magic mirror gefunden
als echte hingeflogen die sternschnuppe
keine ahnung ist nicht so wichtig aber
ich habe noch nie eine gefunden war zu
wissen meteoriten und da fällt das ist
wirklich heftig da ich sehr extrem
die musst du sein soll einfach nur zwei
magic charger warten
feuer feuer gerne boxe ich möchte dir
sternschnuppe finden wir hier erlebt
habe sagte die seiten so sind je werfer
dem mit alter wissen wir haben eine
krise gilt nun die mit auf jeden fall
das ding ist ich hab so viel der boss
ist an den küsten war eigentlich um an
den boss hier im ausreizt dann ist das
so ein penner boxe der springt auf die
kisten und machte dann kaputt
und da ich in ovi weggelockt aber fast
aufgang mehr so wirklich knapp ist er
vorbei gesprungen konnte alle kisten
einfach nur luton wieder das kann ich
hab gedacht ich dachte schon so ich habe
gott unser feld abgeräumt auf einem ich
hab nur zehn würfen obwohl zu 20
megawatt hat auch was im inventar aber
dann hat mich noch ein ganzes spektrum
regen aber natürlich hier die barbas die
pflanzen natürlich auch immer wieder an
muss man natürlich auch tun ist auch
richtig so aber zwei speed behalte ich
mir mal ich wollte meine eigene partei
auch noch da haben sie ein bisschen
alltag ich weit weg wie ich bin gleich
da aber ich schaffe es in dieser folge
nicht 90 minuten 50 sekunden muss an
dieser stelle beenden ich laufe mir
folge wieder zurück und dann werde ich
da ein bisschen weiter bauen wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal macht gut bist ein
schatz
bei mir läuft noch drei minuten weiter
zäh aber ich habe noch ein bisschen zeit
und zwar wollte bush unabhängigen noch
weitermachen
ja genau zwar wollte mir noch eben
kumpels frauen holen um mein haus ein
wenig weiter verbauen so unglaublich es
hat jetzt konnten wir leider nicht
tauschen
ja egal machen bei ihnen anders haben
kann es mir könnte sein dass du mir das
irgendwie meine kiste denke ich leg dir
das in deine kisten bananen ausnahme
weil ich weiß echt noch nicht was ich
jetzt im inventar beim ich habe einen
rucksack der voll ist und mein
momentaner voll ist und alles nur dann
wenn dort der fall ist epics darf alles
vom allerfeinsten dekadent und sowas wie
kein anderes gefährt fts von conaktiv
oh mann ich brauche auf jeden fall ich
weiß nicht wie viel ps verbrauch ich hab
fast gleich einen stack auch so ohne
dass das alte management spitzhacke
abbau aber egal der mann sind ja nicht
so werden folgt eigentlich für
klassische classic 61 habe ich die setzt
jetzt noch eben dahin dass ich wie schön
dass wir langsam tag wie auch bist du
eigentlich schon gestorben ehrlich
gesagt drei mal was wenn erst einmal
gestorben danach war ich voll obwohl ich
so eine whisky schiene vater habe ich
ihm lassen wir das glück ist mit den
dummen wirklich ich weiß gar nicht
irgendwie scheiße und nicht überlebe
einfach aber immer mit einem herzen bin
ich weg weist bei uns regnet gerade
heftig alter ja bei mir ist ja auch so
mehr oder weniger ich hatte gar ich habe
einfach kein glück
aber du dich über leben halt auch nicht
und das war mit geht aus am anfang das
war doof weil ich dachte wirklich dieser
verdacht diese 15 lebenspunkte dennoch
locker erhöht
wer mit stiegen aber die haben halt die
machen so viel schaden alter das ist so
heftig und dann habe ich mit tadel
aufgenommen damit natürlich soll man
richtig vorsichtig vorgehen
dessen creeper bei uns gegen den box
jetzt eben immer eigentlich nur eine
folge auf
mir ist es egal was momentan so wird
erstmal den krieg um geschubst und ich
war zwar ich mache es nicht nach diesem
boden hier und danach wenig aufwändig in
meiner vorne also werdet schon sehen wie
mein haus aussehen wird das wird jetzt
nicht sooo geil sein
ich denke ich werde das auch hier ein
bisschen noch umbauen denke ich ja genau
die wand hier ist das total unnötig wäre
das ja fast nur umbauen alter wie geil
geil das dann werden wir warten hier 12
lautet eins zwei drei vier fünf gebote
bekommt schlechter ein satte 1 2 3 4 5
da muss ich ab hier alles weg reißen so
meine lieben freunde dann würde ich
sagen nächstes mal mein haus wird dann
quasi wenn du das hier so seht es wird
da so dann geht das hier so hoben dann
geht das hier so rum dann kommt hier der
schoko sattel hin
das katz und schoki da kann ich dir
nicht etwas zu essen geben ich gebe
jetzt ein bisschen gruseln einfach
kannst du das nicht ein bisschen essen
willst du dir zu karotten holt sich auf
ihn drauf
nein okay du kriegst dann irgendwas
anderes essen ost wieder eine feder
fallen lassen
schön also leute ihr könnt mir weiterhin
kommentare schreiben wo meine hunde
eigentlich hin sind meine hunde sind
einfach weg ich weiß nicht wieso
teleportieren die sich dann nicht hast
du das gemacht habe ich ja nicht diesen
einfach ich habe eigentlich müssten die
sich teleportieren
vielleicht weil ich mit dem chocobo
gereist bin oder so und wird und so ich
muss eventuell einfach mal wieder ein
bisschen zurück laufen nämlich sagen
vielleicht habe ich überzogen aber es
tut mir dann auf jeden fall leid und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder
wenn es wieder heißt minecraft exit auf
den heroes heran
bis dann